[Música]
y tenemos el análisis también de lo que
ocurre en el terreno en ucrania en esta
guerra y para ello me acompaña en el
estudio más romeros a la mar bienvenida
hoy miércoles porque la guerra en
ucrania ha opacado otro problema
importante y estamos hablando de lo que
vivimos en todo el mundo la pandemia el
19 en que eso se encuentra este país se
respecto a lo que estaba emergencia
sanitaria la pandemia pues la verdad es
que sólo podemos hablar hasta el 24 de
febrero no hay cifras después de eso el
ministerio de salud de hecho hacia un
reporte diario en twitter este es el
mensaje el último mensaje que alcanzaron
a publicar el 24 de febrero con las
cifras del 23 y después de eso la página
de twitter del ministerio de salud se
basa básicamente en informar sobre dónde
conseguir productos médicos de primera
necesidad cómo tratar heridas en
situaciones de emergencia cómo afrontar
los problemas de salud mental que se
pueden derivar de la guerra esta falta
de cifras se ven reflejados en los
conteos internacionales por ejemplo en
el conteo de la universidad johns
hopkins vemos como ucrania estaba
llegando pasaba un pico de contagios y
estaba bajando luego
en el 24 de febrero es donde cae en
picado esa cifra sabíamos que eso que el
pico había llegado el 4 de febrero
aproximadamente con más de 44 mil
fallecimientos y una cosa que de hecho
preocupa es que las muertes de kobe 19
suelen ir dos semanas retrasadas en
estas oleadas entonces puede ser que en
el momento de la invasión también se
estuviera alcanzando se estuviera recién
pasando un pico de muertes por éste
coronavirus más la guerra marc la vacuna
contra coyotes y no podrían entonces
proteger a estas personas en esta
situación de emergencia pues sería lo
más básico lo primordial y podrían
protegerlos si la gente en verdad
estuviera vacunada en ucrania y unos 15
millones de personas inmunizadas contra
el commit 19 pero eso sólo supone el 35
por ciento de la población de todo el
país es la tasa más baja del continente
europeo y refleja la fuerte oposición a
las vacunas que hay en ese país y que
ahora podría tener graves consecuencias
no contagiar y dispersar la enfermedad
también dar más problemas a hospitales
que ya están
de hecho la organización mundial de la
salud que alertó el 27 de febrero que el
suministro de oxígeno podría terminarse
en ucrania en tan sólo 24 horas llegó
precisamente hoy un reporte de la
agencia aip y desde jarc of donde
explicaban cómo vivían la situación y
los problemas que tenían para operar en
estos momentos escuchemos lo
hay mucho personal que no logra llegar
al trabajo desde otras partes así que
intentamos funcionar con el personal que
tenemos los que logran llegar se quedan
aquí
estábamos hablando de estas bajas tasas
de vacunación marc se deben al mismo
contexto de la guerra pues probablemente
no es de hecho esto llega lleva desde
los años desde mediados de los años 2000
y básicamente es una desconfianza hacia
las autoridades que se reflejan en estos
números aunque de hecho el gobierno
ucraniano ha acusado a rusia incluso
antes de que sucediera todo esto de
promover los movimientos antivacunas
para tratar de desestabilizar el país
algo de lo que el kremlin también ha
sido acusado en otros países como
estados unidos el problema como decíamos
es que esto no viene de ahora y no viene
del covent 19 sino que viene desde mucho
antes y por ejemplo ha llevado que
ucrania sea el único país de europa
donde ha habido un rebrote de la polio
el año pasado hubieron dos casos en 2011
hubo un brote en mariupol precisamente y
en principio el 1 de febrero empezó una
campaña masiva para vacunar a todos los
niños pero pues obviamente tuvo que ser
interrumpida por esto por pues por la
invasión rusia de ucrania no es el único
la polio no es la única enfermedad que
vemos que tiene bajas tasas de
vacunación también ocurre con el
sarampión que también ha habido brotes y
también ocurre por ejemplo con la
tuberculosis vemos que en todos estos
casos las cifras de las tasas están por
debajo de la recomendación de la
organización mundial de la salud para
evitar rebrotes de estas enfermedades es
por eso que la unión europea por ejemplo
pues ya prometió que va a distribuir
todas estas vacunas en las fronteras
donde lleguen los refugiados pues madre
entonces gracias por toda esta
información en este contexto de guerra y
lo que está pasando con las enfermedades
también el kobe 19 problemas también
mayores que lamentablemente se ven un
poco apagados por este problema mayor a
ella si se quiere decir
en el plano inmediato que está derramar
muchísimo con alimentan eso es
importante decir no hay uno más
importante sino que se retraen sí sí y
martí pero también tenemos un poco más
de tiempo entonces le quiero preguntar
los riesgos de brotes de la enfermedad
es que debe ser más altos en contextos o
de guerra no como como precisamente le
estaba diciendo claro de hecho por
muchos motivos no por un lado porque
esas tasas de vacunaciones son bajas eso
pues todavía es peor en momentos donde
las aglomeraciones como en los flujos
migratorios en los refugios van a ser
mayores también por la falta de higiene
la falta de agua potable puede de brotes
de enfermedades como el cólera sin ir
más lejos y tercero por la interrupción
de tratamientos de enfermedades
infecciosas que son vitales como la
tuberculosis o el vih un 1 por ciento de
la población en ucrania vive con vih
sólo la mitad está con tratamientos
antirretrovirales entonces pues en estos
casos de conflictos bélicos si se
interrumpen estos tratamientos corremos
el riesgo de que haya rebrotes y de que
estos rebrotes no sólo sucedan en
ucrania sino que también se desplacen a
los demás países de alrededor mar y
todavía por supuesto no sabemos no
tenemos una bolita de cristal como diría
nuestro compañero santiago lópez para
saber qué va a pasar en ucrania pero que
nos cuenta el pasado sobre las epidemias
y también las guerras digamos estas
enfermedades en el contexto bélico
terminamos eso con un poquito de
historia alrededor de esto porque
sabemos desde incluso el tiempo de los
romanos que las enfermedades pueden
hacer ganar y perder guerras y que
además también son abono para estas
guerras de estos conflictos bélicos son
abono para estas enfermedades no lo
vimos sin ir más lejos en la
colonización en el genocidio también del
continente americano por parte de los
europeos como una de las principales
causas que apoyó pues la victoria de los
europeos sobre los pueblos originarios
pero es que también lo vimos en la
primera guerra mundial se desató la
llamada gripe española mató entre 20 y
50 millones de personas y contagió hasta
un tercio de la población mundial de
hecho provocó más muertes que la propia
guerra entonces tenemos que estar
pendientes de qué sucede ahora porque
como decíamos estamos en un contexto
donde el conflicto bélico y la pandemia
se pueden retroalimentar también con
esas bajas tasas de vacunación entonces
pues sabemos que tendremos que estar
pendientes y que es un tema que no
podemos desatender seguramente no hay
para eso estamos aquí hablando con usted
mar muchísimas gracias entonces por toda
esta información